bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans l'émission
à 6 ans par les sports intalk sur
l'actualité sportive du département vous
connaissez désormais le programme il y
aura des coups de gueule des analyses
des débats et des duels quatre
chroniqueurs sont en plateau aujourd'hui
présentation de nos quatre fantastiques
en musique
notre premier fantastique est un
cycliste qu'il est vice champion du
monde de cyclisme sur piste master's
champion d'europe en 2013 si vous le
cherchez les tout le temps au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
pour s'entraîner je veux bien sûr parler
de yann dujarrier bon sens la garenne
bonsoir
alors vous êtes venus comment
aujourd'hui voiture en voiture en vélo
maintenant à vous casser le mythe on
passe de l'autre côté ils entraînent
aller bélascain les moins de 21 ans de
rugby club de versailles il est adepte
du beau jeu des chisteras et des
troisièmes mi temps je veux bien sûr
parler de guillaume deroff tenir 9h09 ce
sera bien j'arrive vous allez bien ou
très bien merci
il va en découdre toujours avec vos
collègues via le parisien
on passe de l'autre côté il entraîne je
reviens à vous il entraîne le club de
rugby de plaisir il est de bonne humeur
aujourd'hui son club est en route pour
la montée en fédérale 2 jean miss est
avec nous vous allez bien gens ont pu
quand vous allez au fond vous avez
réviser vos fiches parce que d'habitude
vous avez radouci est là vous n'avez pas
de dossier âgées pas de dossier j'ai
tout dans la tête aujourd'hui parfait on
termine par notre dernier fantastique
musique on le surnomme l'encyclopédie du
sport hubinois cdi des chroniqueurs et
les liquides lors de la msl messi neymar
suarez dans les yvelines
vas-y l'alcool y est avec nous sur ce
plateau tschaen présentation bon ça va
dit le manager michel sanaa trailer vous
pas besoin de fiches mais vous avez tout
dans la tête c'est exactement ici
j'espère en tout cas vous serez au
niveau de votre réputation
on va passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du club de handball du chéné de
monty bretenoux nous allons parler de
l'escrimeuse diane von kant cercas
sommes brook mais tout de suite coup de
projecteur sur l'aviron
les régates de versailles compétition
centenaire était organisée ce dimanche
13 mars sur le grand canal du château
organisée tous les deux ans le rendez
vous a attiré plus de 1200 rameurs de 35
clubs
les sportifs sont venus de la région
parisienne de roi en deux camps de
compiègne et même de turin en italie on
écoute l'organisateur jacques bosc
les rameurs en de 12 13 ans aux vétérans
sans limite d'âge il n'y a pas de dents
je sûr il n'ya pas de sélection sur ces
courses
c'est simplement une course de début de
saison mais qui permet d'étalonner quand
même les équipes parce que les équipages
du vainqueur à versailles ils sont
souvent sur les podiums nationaux en
forme de ce nom vous l'avez entendu
cette compétition est avant tout amicale
et aident à préparer les grands
événements de la saison nous notre
question sur ce thème les régates de
versailles c'est avant tout une
compétition pour promouvoir l'aviron oui
ou non vous votez vous êtes tous
d'accord
merci il y a quand même non pas lui car
vous n'êtes pas d'accord d'accord alors
un petit duel entre vous guillaume et
allégeant ses parties non je peux
d'accord alors en effet ces promenades
iapps est pas qu on trouvera l'amour ou
l'aviron pardon en effet le bassin de
canal est un site extraordinaire pour
pratiquer l'aviron ça c'est sûr je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de rameurs qui rêvent
de ramer sur ce bassin la français ou
italiens ont la vie mais matin cécile
l'audi préparation là les matches de la
saison donc ce n'est pas qu'une
promotion d'aviron c'est aussi une
préparation pour les rameurs pour la
saison qui va s'ouvrir incessamment sous
peu un genre qu'est ce que vous répondez
à guillaume verney
mais oui d'écouter la raison de notre
côté il a tort tout simplement parce que
cette compétition là quand même
elle est qu un fait ils l'ont dit c'est
pas les compétitions quoi c'est vraiment
une préparation c'est plus la
convivialité c'est plus un phénomène de
masse que de vraiment de l'élitisme donc
forcément forcément qui dit man qui dit
phénomène de masse dit pour promouvoir
la discipline et pour faut savoir quand
même que l'aviron
je crois de mémoire ses 43 milles
licencié mais c'est sa 1000e pratique
donc la plus pour moi cette compétition
si on peut appeler ça compétition cet
événement où cette activité
ce rassemblement où cet événement c'est
plus quand même pour promouvoir la
discipline
bon alors si je peux rajouter juste
enfin on fait tout ce que ce soit
quelque soit le sport des matches de
préparation en début de saison donc
c'est un peu aussi ça fait aussi un peu
office de préparation d'une arthur pour
la saison quoi donc
donc c'est à moi je trouve moche à un
mix des deux simples de deux
d'événements festifs et épreuve
promotionnelle et préparation pour les
rameurs qui sont passés quand même il ya
quand même il ya quand même un an je
vois là mais ça ne s'était pas
l'interview d'un rameur tu aurais pu me
dire quelles sont les motivations qui
n'ont pu amener à venir à venir sur
versailles avait des rameurs versailles
a en tout cas pour eux c'était très
important forcément parce que la
compétition était à versailles c'est un
domicile après pour mais pourquoi
pourquoi kelly pourquoi ce turin sont
venus par exemple bon ça serait quand
même parce que versailles mais voilà
parce que versailles mais voilà mais ça
c'est ce que je voulais entendre c'est
d'évidence et bien sûr c'est un mix des
deux ponts n'ont même pas eu
d'adversaire et aussi fait partie des
meilleurs clubs d'aviron nos francs qui
d'ailleurs l'atout barouki et voilà donc
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs simplement ta
roue qui avait remporté les régates de
versailles je pense que basile vous
pouvez me le confirmer c'était non
maintenant et bien à sion et du coup ça
y est peut-être pour la pousser les
jeunes du couvert vers l'avant justement
vers le devant de la scène peut-être âme
d'avoir un turnover hook de l'aviron
abbas assure pouvoir organiser un
événement dans un site pareil un
dimanche après midi ensoleillé je pense
qu'il ya pas mieux et également pour
faire parler de ce sport au grand public
parce que je pense qu'il y avait
également des visiteurs qui sont venus
passer l'après midi uniquement poids
pour flâner dans le parc du château
qu'on doit être surpris de voir autant
de monde
la lady voilà ce sera au tour du grand
canal et c'est vrai que c'est une
occasion formidable
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de sport ce
qu'ils aimeraient avoir un spot comme
celui là quelle que soit la discipline
qui est pratiqué ou et puis justement
organiser de tels événements et ça c'est
pas possible partout donc là c'est vrai
que je pense que l'aviron l'avion sur
versailles a un un avenir encore bien
bien tracée pour pour les pour les
années pour les années à venir parce que
parce que ça doit être un vrai plaisir
de pouvoir à ramer ramer ici quoi le
sport a besoin réellement d'avoir ce
type de manifestation pour exister pour
pour grandir comme beaucoup beaucoup de
sport en france et voilà il existe tous
les quatre ans on en parle seulement
lors des jeux olympiques
rarement pendant les championnats du
monde alors que c'est par pas par
expérience mais par
j'en ai j'en ai parlé avec avec pas mal
de gens et c'est vrai que c'est un sport
où les sportifs sont sont des sportifs
complets
sait on est on est pendant une courte
période c'est des régates qui doit faire
cinq six minutes je crois quand sur le
sur les épreuves olympiques et on est
quand même très très haut dans les dents
les pulls cependant pendant ces cinq six
mutés donc il faut vraiment le tenir et
au niveau musculaire musculature
musculaire c'est aussi une grosse grosse
demande d'énergie donc et puis les
tournois son nom aussi parce qu'il ya
des tours à passer c'est pas un effort
que l'on que l'on répète donc c'est vrai
que c'est un sport très complet et qui
les socios ne porte pas que mais en tout
cas ce port technique sport collectif il
ya du matériel il ya plein de choses que
c'est quelque chose qui doit très
intéressant pratiquer et comment faire
adhérer justement les gens à ce sport au
quotidien soit en faisant des événements
pareils soit en effet en ouvrant les
faisant des portes ouvertes en fait
finalement à la découverte
ils ont un spot qui est dans le château
de versailles qui peuvent profiter de ce
spot là pour essayer de faire des
journées portes ouvertes avec elle et
les joggeurs qui viennent courir les f1
qui ce qui vient de faire du vélo les
promeneurs le seuil d'une pique nique et
je pense qu'il ya pas mal de choses à
faire comme c'est qu'un promeneur ou en
vigueur ce n'est pas toujours un sportif
et là je pense que pour pouvoir rétablir
entre la découverte et le faut toucher
pour pouvoir être piquée après par la
fin
lloris donc donc pour avoir la masse
pour avoir la basse je pense que là il
ya quelque chose de vraiment rageant
c'est que je les propose est souvent
dans mes séminaires et il vous dit que
j'organise excusez-moi de placer et les
gens qui découvrent ce sport là c'est
hyper lui dit quand tu les connais pas
ses bottes notion de découverte
si les périodiques et au bout d'une
heure les bateaux à quatre ils arrivent
très navré à ramer à glisser sur l'eau
il trouve une sensation extraordinaire
et souvent à la fin de cette journée là
il ya des gens qui demandent des enfants
club mais quand est-ce que je peux venir
m'inscrire et c'est donc je pense que on
ouvre un peu plus les portes aux gens
qui passent et c'est tellement à
versailles je pense qu'il pourrait
encore grandir et après la compétition
c'est autre chose il ya la vie en loisir
l'aviron compétition où le sport juste
pour s'entretenir en fin de jeu j'ai une
grosse aql et oui mais pas que moi j'ai
un gros j'ai un gros problème dans la
définition du sportif c'est que
quelqu'un qui va faire son jogging tous
les dimanches il pour moi il fait pas de
la course à pied il ya une grosse
différence voilà entre la personne qui
accroche un dossard et la personne qui
va nager tous les dimanches et celui qui
va se taper des kilomètres tous les
jours pour pouvoir être compétitif des
sports entretient l'espoir compétition
fins par loisir je pense que moi j c'est
quand même un discours que j'ai très
régulièrement avec les gens ont du mal à
comprendre tu viens tu sais très bien
que dans tous les clubs sportifs
on a besoin des genres des coupes de
cheveux fins de licencier donc de
loisirs mais l'édition il faut il fait
tout pour pour faire un plein sportif
quoi sur l'acte sur le dông hà après
cette page aviron on passe au handball
on continue donc ce talk part du
handball promu cette saison le
chesnay-versailles montigny le
bretonneux sont au bord de la relégation
les chez les siens sont pour le moment à
l'avant dernière place du classement de
nationale 2 avec 4 points de retard sur
le premier non relégable saint maur la
situation des féminines de montillot
bretonneux est encore plus préoccupante
lésigny monteyne son dernière de
national une après leur défaite contre
octeville 23 à 11
la question qui peut se maintenir rouge
pour le chesnay et vert continue salon
rouge toulouse à voter tant qu' on vous
retrouve à l'écran et à basile qui est
partagé moi je pense que les deux
peuvent encore le bien qu'ils se
maintenir mathématiquement les deux
comme titulaire vous basile et vous y
allez partie de ma vie j'avais ma vie de
lui pour l'instant voix pour les jets un
petit peu regardé alésia léger j'ai un
petit peu regardez c'est vrai que les
deux peuvent encore se maintenir
maintenant la prochaine journée de
championnat est déterminante pour les
garçons parce qu'il rencontre le dernier
et donc si une paire nous devons avoir
un trou qui sera trop importants par
rapport aux voilà au premier aurait
d'ailleurs voilà le premier non
relégable n'ont quoi y aurait sept
points d'écart si sa mort si ça mord
gagne ce sera vraiment trop compliqué
maintenant chez les filles en effet
elles sont dernière mais elles n'ont
qu'un point de retard sur les trois
précédentes et donc du coup là il ya
vraiment du maintien le phare le
maintien n'est pas feinte le jeu n'est
pas encore fait et surtout que les
filles vont rencontrer la 7e la huitième
la 9e le relais c'est déjà bien
ouais voilà sur un match un match sur
les cibles maxi sept matches qui leur
restent séparés mais lavaur et avons
rencontré quand des équipes qui sont en
bas de tableau qui ne vont peut-être pas
non plus jouer la relégation
donc il ya je pense encore que les deux
pour les deux équipes sont encore encore
maintenable mais ça va jouer sur sur les
tous prochains matchs parce qu'après
deux ans ce sera trop tard mais mais
pour moi voilà si on regarde que le
pourquoi ce que j'ai dit les filles
c'est parce que si on regarde le tableau
les filles deux prétendantes qui sont
juste à un point donc mathématiquement
c'est plus facile ce serait peut-être
plus facile pour elle que pour tous pour
les garçons voilà basile je passe la
parole à je suis assez d'accord avec ce
que ce qu'on vient d'entendre qui peut
se maintenir bas pour l'instant on a vu
du classement les deux équipes qui ont
une situation un peu similaire puisque
elles m'ont toutes les filles sont
montées cette année les gars ont su
remonter c'était l'objectif pour les
deux équipes et le calendrier de fin de
saison est un peu le même également pour
le chesnais qui vous rencontré que des
formations de deuxième partie de
classement après qu' ici si on doit se
mouiller qui va se maintenir je miserais
plus sur l'équipe féminine de montigny
qui a un groupe on va dire beaucoup plus
homogène qui défia qu'ils connaissent
depuis de nombreuses années qu'ont
l'habitude de jouer ensemble
un nouveau coach qui est arrivé depuis
quelques semaines donc ça veut dire un
nouvel élan dans l'équipe avec un
nouveau jeu mis en place plus porté vers
l'avant donc ça peut peut-être être la
solution qui va leur permettre de rester
en n1 les garçons c'est plus compliqué
je crois qu'ils n'ont qu'une seule
victoire au compteur
il ya eu un recrutement l'été dernier
qui pour l'instant ne semble pas
vraiment fonctionné ça y'a pas
l'alchimie qui c'est qui ce tellement
créé dans l'est dans l'équipe donc je
suis un peu plus dubitatifs sur les
chances de maintien du duchesnay je vois
bouillir à côté de noms enfin voila on
avait parlé un petit peu dans l'émission
sur les défis notamment enfin et c'est
vrai que enfin que les filles les trois
dernières elles jouent toutes les 3 4 3
4 matchs à domicile ajoute les trouve
toutes les trois sur les images qui
restent trois filles du taux de pain du
top6 donc les autres c'est du top 20 bas
de tableau donc voilà c'est sexy du
50-50 voilà je pense que les filles - un
peu plus de chance que le chesnay de se
maintenir notamment que notre faim
notamment dans le fait qu chez nathan
départ il ya des rumeurs qui courent
comme quoi l'ambiance c'est pas tip top
100 du groupe
voilà donc donc je pense que c'est un
peu plus que ça des plus compliqués
professionnels enfin c'est mon avis ou
parler globalement de des matches qui
aura à jouer mais il peut y avoir
également un exploit gens me disent par
exemple parce qu'on parle par exemple de
montigny s'il y aura peut-être que deux
champions début de saison mais moi non
mais là par contre la voie des exploits
oui oui il peut y voir les exploits mais
je reviens sur ce que je lis basile le
fait d'avoir un nouvel entraîneur lui
prend ça pour un nouvel élan là je
réagis toujours un petit peu en tant
qu'entraîneur et
c'est pas évident quand même de mettre
en place quelque chose rapidement
bien sûr d'accord et moi je vise plutôt
plus justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
voté un peu contre vous parce que j'ai
mise plus sur la continuité et ce qui
est en place
parce que c'est plus facile
effectivement de créer un exploit
lorsqu'on a un groupe qu'on connaît et
qui est capable de le faire sur un
ressort psychologique que sur la mise en
place avec un nouvel un nouvel
entraîneur qui a besoin qu'un petit peu
plus de temps c'est uniquement pour ça
que je dis moi je fais un petit peu j'ai
prêché s'est fait l'avocat du diable
senneff dans les clous où il ya en tout
est si compliqué avec une seule victoire
et ses cils et groovy pas très bien
enfin is a permis aux tensions dans le
groupe
oui et je sais qu'elle est justement
ramener justement un sport collectif
notamment dans le handball se rapproche
du rugby pour une raison ou pour une
autre
on sait pas pourquoi il peut y avoir un
déclic collectif en disant hé bé est bon
on va se faire suis là on va se le faire
le match important au michael parler
d'un exploit et bien ce match important
on va se le faire et on va y arriver et
j'y crois plus - là dessus parce que
c'est toujours pareil toujours là le
collectif et puis le handball c'est un
petit peu proche du rugby mais ce n'est
pas faire du combat
non le handball ce proche de te reste
rapproche moi moi dans l'esprit d'un
état d'esprit mais je miserais plus pur
sauf que là on est arrivé à un point
dans l'équipe féminine de montigny où il
y avait vraiment un clash qui était
entre l'entraîneur qui était en place
avant et certaines joueuses
à tel point que communication donc là un
moment c'était oui mais non je les
trouve bah si c'est bénéfique
ce changement d'entraîneur d'après on
verra on verra on verra enfin en fin de
saison
en tout cas c'est parce que c'est une
fois que le nouveau est arrivé à gagner
un match à 1.163 et voilà oui mais
justement c'est l'effet belges ont perdu
un autre match juste après voilà c'est
l'effet kiss cool c'est à dire ce
nouveau nouveau
donc là on marque le coup parce que on
en souffre et on a tout fait pour virer
l'entraîneur puisqu'il ya eu un clash
donc au niveau des joueurs des joueurs
là on marque le coup et on gagne des
points mais après mais j'aurais tendance
à dire chassez le naturel il revient au
galop
et est-ce qu est-ce que sur la fin de
saison est ce que c'était vraiment la
faute de l'entraîneur avant oui après on
n'est pas la tâche de l'entraîneur c'est
le fusible valeurs collectives faut que
le nouvel entraîneur s'appuie sur le
petit déclic qui a eu pour réussir à les
leur cherche quelqu'un là est recherché
mais ça c'est difficile
et si on nous traite ici sur la vie de
groupe parce que la vie de groupe elles
des filles vivent mieux que les garçons
jusqu'à ce fameux en tout cas le nouvel
entraîneur nous l'avons reçue en plateau
dans le 7-8 sport il est plutôt
optimiste on écoute depuis quinze jours
on travaille des fils travaille beaucoup
s'investissent beaucoup elles ne sont
avides d'apprendre et de mettre en
application hélas contre octeville ça
peut plus le faire mais moi je reste
persuadé comme le disait christophe que
les matchs qui vont être à notre portée
il arrive au mois d'avril le mois
d'avril va être capital je pense que ça
va le faire parce que les filles vont
être là bon il est plutôt optimiste jean
miss mais par contre ce qu'il le fait de
dire que les filles ont envie
d'apprendre
je sais pas si à ce niveau de la saison
ça c'est trop tard on apprend plus on
apprend ça fait quand même dit ça je
pense que ça va compter sur un groupe à
montigny très jeune avec des demoiselles
qu'on 16 17 18 ans qui sont encore en
apprentissage en formation non parce que
l'équipe féminine des moins de 18 ans
n'existe plus cette année à montigny
dont elle passe directement de cadettes
à l'équipe senior vu mais c'est ce que
je dis c'est le second en apprentissage
je suis d'accord donc on va là partent
déjà à la saison prochaine voilà la base
il voit là parce que moi moi je reste
persuadé je reste persuadé qu'en même
qu'il faut un temps pour mettre un jeu
en place un collectif une évidence
il faut un temps c'est pas un coup de
baguette magique j'arrive je suis nouvel
entraîneur elles ont envie d'apprendre
oui mais il faut le talent quand même
pour mettre en place un meilleur
collectif il faut du temps avec ses
autres objectifs maintien pour les six
mois qu'il a fait puis et boulot pour la
descente après principauté ainsi
compliqué à gérer c'est pas ça par
contre rocher n'est pas de changement
vous pensez que c'est la bonne solution
à base il faut faire des impasses que
vous êtes premier en ce moment j'en vis
mais j'ai connu aussi le contraire en
voiture et vous paye les musiciens à la
fin la fin du smic cela fait du balcon
peu cessa de vers à la verra à la fin de
saison mais il n'y a pas besoin
peut-être justement d'un déclic par
contre aux chaînés par contre pour le
coup il n'y avait l'ambiance était pas
forcément beau fixe d'après ce que vous
avez dit
guillaume vous nous avez aussi dit en
début d'analysé de but de questionnaires
de présentation c'est qu'ils viennent de
monter dans la division des deux là
avaient avec avec une est une équipe qui
monte en plus où on enlève l'équipe
moins de 18 ou non mais défi qu'ont 16
17 ans pour aller jouer contre des
contres des seigneurs des filles qu'on
peut être plus d'expérience dans
d'autres équipes faut laisser le temps
et voilà et c'est peut-être un petit peu
compliqué et puis chez les gars il faut
aussi un peu le temps pour s'habituer au
nouveau rythme des matches hier montrons
l'attendrir défendu avec montrons
l'année prochaine et les suivantes on
leur souhaite
et puis ils ont quand même eu une année
une année supplémentaire des files
d'années d'expérience et et puis bah ça
peut être ça peut être suffisant pour
pour la suite mais voilà on y ont bien
on voit deux clubs qui font du yoyo qui
montrent une année et puis qui
redescendent directement les suivants
les spurs et voilà c'est donc en ligue 1
de football voilà donc c'est s'est passé
pas c'est pas grave quoi ils n'ont pas
su garder la dynamique de montée et
attendait est-ce que c'est pas non plus
le club qui avait fait trois montées
successives montigny trois montées
successives des trois dernières années
non ok je veux dire après cette page
résultat on passe maintenant la
chronique j'aime j'aime pas de notre
encyclopédie vivante base il a rigolé
notre chroniqueur yann cédric daury nous
présente ces tops et les flops du
week-end dans le département on commence
tout de suite par le premier j'aime
jingle alors vas-y de votre premier gm
concerne la gymnastique exactement et le
club d'elancourt maurepas les filles de
ce club ont participé ce week-end au top
12 alors qu'est ce que le top 12
c'est en fait le championnat de france
par équipes en gymnastique qui rassemble
les 12 meilleurs clubs de france
c'est la deuxième fois de leur histoire
que le club d'elancourt maurepas va y
participer la dernière fois c'était en
donc elles ont réussi l'an dernier le
folder le petit exploit de terminer
deuxième de la deuxième division
française et donc de décrocher leur
billet et pourquoi un j'aime parce
qu'elles vont se présenter ce week-end
en vendée avec une équipe 100% française
parmi eux c'est le seul club des douze
présents qui alignera que des gymnastes
tricolore et surtout formé au club issu
issus du département
a contrario on retrouve dans les autres
formations présentes des ukrainiennes
des russes des hongroises qu'on verra
sûrement cet été aux jeux olympiques
donc affaire à suivre
évidemment avec un objectif de maintien
au top 12 qui serait un bel exploit avec
l'effectif aligné genre mais s'il ya
plus de mérite de monter une équipe avec
des joueuses du cru des joueuses locales
bah oui c'est sûr importe quelle
discipline
je suis pas je suis pas spécialiste la
gymnastique
on dit merci et je le fais mais comme je
le fais vraiment
après un soir de monter je suis pas un
spécialiste mais quoi qu'il arrive
sportivement c'est bien que de figurer
dans les meilleurs avec en plus
effectivement que des sportifs du cru
des sportifs du cru qui sont toujours
plus valorisant pour un club que d'aller
chercher des étrangers entre guillemets
comme disait basile pour simplement
monter le niveau de la discipline
rappelle bien c'est là qu'ils avaient
tout raflé aux ile de france et jean la
fin
exact médailles sur est ce qu'on dit
exprimant tout raflé mois mais ouais pas
tout raflé à 95%
yann excuse moi je suis mais c'est
l'école des fans on a échappé à la
question c'est un club qui forme est
vraiment où c'est un cap qui recrutait
autour de lui pour après continuer la
formation quoi c'était plus apparemment
un club qui les deux un peu comme au
rugby un peu comme bassi qui va attirer
des joueurs à lui et après les côtoient
les formes et dont une licence oui non
je vois tu sais c'est un peu les deux
bref on accorde bien ses balles
manquantes des gym class heroes in what
we même de la communauté d'agglomération
de saint quentin aisne vient ici elles
sont pas directement une encore toutes
mes forces à deux on avait juste un
exemple d'une d'une fille chez eux d'une
jeune d'une fille chez eux qui vient du
30 17
mais elle vient parce que
ouais étrangères mais parce que parce
que là la formation avec sa lite enfin
c'est une élite l'élite par un mille de
france élite yvelinois et par miner les
deux trois clubs phares de l'île de
france a c'est indéniable donc c'est
vrai que pour ses pour elle ce week-end
ça va être un week-end qui restera parce
que pouvoir se confronter à des
étrangères qui sont sur le circuit
international
ça n'arrive pas tous les jours et c'est
vous c'est vrai en route un autre ton
c'est une police où on peut fonctionner
sur le long terme on pensait à guillaume
oui bien sûr pas fort un budget deux
fois mais formé à bout de plusieurs
général que que de recruter des joueurs
directement directement forme est donc
enfin avoir de l'argent après une
boutique de clubs de président le prise
par le bureau a décidé de faire cette
politique là et moi je peux qu'approuver
ça maintenant il sait tout dépend après
les objectifs à moyen terme et à long
terme qui sont mis est ce que l'artiste
amateur dans le top-12 absolument 6eme
30 ans le 12 peut-être qu'après fera
faire d'autres choses parce que comme
dit vasile d'après il ya les clubs turcs
rue des ukrainiennes défunt des défis de
l'est donc moi la presse et à court
terme c'est super et pouvoir main à
moyen terme et à long terme qu'elle est
proche du club et vers quoi ils veulent
cette journée provisions yann c la
détection vraiment qui fait la
différence dans cette politique je pense
c'est plutôt la formation qui fait la
différence
et puis après peut-être des questions
des jeunes talents du secteur des petits
voient la détection de nan mais
formation des jeunes talents du site sur
tout simplement tirer le meilleur d'un
athlète c'est pas c'est parce qu'il ya
de plus compliqué parce qu'être plus
compliqué
il faut il faut se demander confiance et
puis avoir les possibilités de le faire
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
donc si l'on la structure la sauce au
dessus suffisante et ben et puis et puis
ben l'amour de cette formation ben voila
voila il sait mais il arrive à récolter
les résultats on passe au deuxième
j'aime de basile jingle il concerne les
scream il n'y a pas que les mines oise
astrid guyart qui rafle les médailles
qui ravit les pieds qui est également
depuis ce week-end qualifié fille brûlée
pour les jeux olympiques de rio en
battant en quarts de finale la
championne olympique italienne qui font
de ces scans donc j'ai déjà fait cela on
va on peut la féliciter mais cette fois
on va parler d'une hotte escrimeuse
beaucoup plus jeune seulement 17 ans
elle est licenciée au club du chéné
s'appelle diane 24 brook cette
demoiselle a
a participé le week-end dernier aux
championnats d'europe juniors en serbie
pour sa première année dans la catégorie
elle est devenue vice championne
d'europe avec par équipe avec ses
coéquipières de l'équipe de france est
21e en individuel alors c'est une belle
performance parce que sortir puis
mondial depuis le début de saison depuis
depuis septembre elle n'avait encore
jamais réussi à monter sur un podium par
équipe les françaises à chaque fois
c'était des 5e 6e 7e place et puis là il
ya eu un quart de finale contre les
grandes favorites les grandes favorites
c'était les italiennes elles ont réussi
à faire cet exploit est derrière elle on
rejoint là les demi finales puis la
finale se sont inclinés contre les
russes je crois donc voilà une petite
jeune qui monte qui va participer ce
week-end qui repartit déjà l'air venu de
serbie elle est repartie au genre et
repart aujourd'hui en roumanie pour
disputer sa première coupe du monde
senior à seulement 17 ans et puis elle
enchaîne
donc un dans dix jours sur le
championnat du monde junior qui aura
lieu à bourges donc elle n'arrête pas
voilà ça à la sonara ça n'arrête pas et
on lui souhaite de si bons résultats que
celui obtenu en serbie c'est la relève
vraiment à votre avis à base in c'est
que la relève des grands causses grande
escrimeuse vivre ces épées et épée
fleuret et là c'est la grande relève
je pense là de la fédération leur père
et lui a proposé l'été dernier
d'intégrer le pôle espoir à talence donc
l argent l'aquitaine en septembre elle
s'entraîne avec avec la génération
montante et preuve des fruits de son
travail c'est que voilà elle a été
sélectionnée pour représenter dans deux
jours l'équipe de france sur le circuit
mondial en seniors à seulement 17 ans
donc il ya de bons espoirs dans cette
demoiselle guillaume on a besoin de
renouveler les scream
on l'a fait un zéro pointé aux jo
oui mais justement les les problèmes
importants
la pratique de ce sport là en fait c'est
que c'est enfin les en france ça
quasiment le seul pays où les escrimeurs
les tireurs sont pas professionnels
c'est à dire qu'ils ont un travail et un
métier à côté en prend aux italiennes
par exemple qui a en fleuret rafle tous
depuis des années des années notamment
via l'italie qui est championne
olympique depuis c'est la plus grande
des enfants voilà c'est la plus grande
médaille olympique à la qualité de 4,4
quatre titres olympiques par non
individuelle je crois à lesperon quoi
allait provoquer en plus toute la
journée toute 365 jours par an enfin
voilà quoi
et en france bat on a un métier où le
matin les ennuis c'est plus c'est plus à
un système qu'il faut changer puisque
pour avoir des escrimeurs compétitif à
ce niveau que des générations les
générations a toujours eu des bons
rounds a toujours une bonne formation en
escrime en france il ya parfois pas se
leurrer après c'est un problème de voile
à 2 de moyens amateurs contrefaire
semi-pro contre pro quoi donc du coup
assez compliqué quoi de pour avoir des
titres vous est admiratif devant asus et
comme celui là yann admiratif pour
l'instant moi je faire voilà pour
l'instant je vois une 21e place
individuelle sur 90 participants ont
donc la première place
pour moi ça veut rien dire voilà c'est
ça ça ressemble à rien par contre en
effet une médaille par équipes ça c'est
très très motivant pour se faire l'écho
par contre à une médaille une médaille
par équipes ça c'est super motivant
c'est qu'à ou du mans revient d'un
championnat et on ne revient pas avec
une spirale négative on revient avec
quelque chose et ça c'est très important
maintenant voilà elle est allée dans
entre les mains de la fédération elle
est
donc faut lui laisser le temps
d'apprendre faut lui laissant de
progresser on lui donne l'opportunité
d'aller faire un championnat senior
alors qu'elle n'a que 17 ans donc elle
va apprendre énormément faux-pas
faux-pas faut pas rêver non plus sur sur
ce type de première compétition physique
il est bien sûr trop bien je suis en
bien sûr j'imagine que c'est pareil les
les matchs ne sont pas les mêmes et
l'intensité n'est pas la même le nombre
de matches n'est peut-être pas non plus
le même entrain junior est un seigneur
j'ai pas toutes les informations sur sur
les screen mais nous voilà il faut aider
tant mieux pour elle maintenant ben à
elle de montrer qu'on va parler d'elle
pendant très longtemps et pour revenir à
ce que ce que vous dites c'est vrai qu'
on ne voit là avec les championnats du
monde de biathlon
ben nos athlètes en biathlon ils sont
hyper forme mais parce que ben ils sont
soutenus par l'armée ils sont tous ils
sont tous militaires donc est détaché et
donc du coup peuvent se permettre de
travailler sérieusement pendant neuf
mois 9 mois de l'année et heureusement
que l'armée est là pour pouvoir les
soutenir en passe maintenant aux j'aime
pas jingle on va parler de l'équipe
oui on va rester on va rester au chesnay
avec l'équipe de football qui évolue en
excellence départementale donc la plus
haute division au niveau département la
trêve elle était plutôt bien bien classé
deuxième derrière lee mais avec un début
de saison pour le moins très
encourageant avec un objectif qu'il ya
un petit peu le psg
locale voilà voilà elle aimait le
chesnay en début de saison un objectif
sur court moyen terme c'est de remonter
en promotion d'honneur au niveau
régional et puis la sueur sur les
derniers matches on reconnaît plus du
tout cette équipe du chéné qui enchaîne
qui enchaîne les défaites quatre
défaites consécutives avec des scores
très sévère 4-1 à maurepas la semaine
dernière 4 0 contre la réserve de
versailles la semaine précédant ses 15
buts encaissés là sur les quatre
derniers matchs ça veut dire 50% des
buts encaissés depuis le début de saison
qu'ils viennent eux de les prendre en
quatre journées de championnat
donc voilà il souviennent de ceux qui
viennent de descendre du podium et puis
bah le championnat il est encore il est
encore long va falloir qu'ils réagissent
vite faire attention parce que cette
année on va avoir des clubs yvelinois
qui vont descendre du niveau régional ça
veut dire qu'il va sûrement et même très
certainement quatre descentes en fin de
saison
donc quand on regarde derrière il ya le
cas si on parle de la fin les murs eux
sont sept points derrière eux c'est
d'ailleurs justement les mureaux qui
vont recevoir dimanche une cinquième
défaite contre contre le premier
relégable
ça ferait plus que quatre ou cinq points
de différence donc ça peut être une
deuxième partie de saison très
dangereuse pour pour l'équipe du chesnay
signer son développement ou aussi qu'ils
ou qu'un point de retard sur le deuxième
donc c'est pareil voilà maintenant il ya
les vignes ça va vite dans l'immédiat à
catus 20 et après le reste deuxième et
après on fait de la deuxième place à la
dernière page il serait pour le maintien
quoi si on pousse à quatre places qui
descendent kiên enfin c'est là c'est là
ça va être des matches après il y en a
un qui commence dès dimanche avec
justement les mureaux et comment
s'expliquent justement cette frilosité
en défense vas-y problème avec un arrêt
des ventes jugées reprendre une phrase
célèbre grand problème en défense
puisque messi wayne on n'est même pas si
je n'aime pas un problème forcément des
effectifs comme on peut l'entendre
souvent un matin gardien après après les
après les défaites mais peut-être un
manque de concentration sur ces matches
est très positif et un relâchement qui
s'est fait autant la photo
automatiquement et comment on explique
justement qu'une équipe marche si bien
en première partie de saison et
s'écroule totalement en seconde partie
de saison
alors finalement les joueurs sont les
mêmes ouais non mais simplement parce
qu'en début de saison
ce que l'objectif pour le club était
était la montée là quand on voit ali
mais avec 20 points d'avancé
et qu'on sait quand on sait que c'est le
premier qui monte je pense que la
démotivation elle se fait d'elle-même en
disant mon mais c'est plus la peine on
montrera pas donc c'est plus la peine de
c'est peut-être sexe qui explique cette
deuxième partie de saison
ce début de 2ème partie de saison où
c'est un petit peu plus c'est la cata
cette fois c'est catastrophique
maintenant maintenant la presse que l'on
se doit se ressaisir ils vont se
ressaisir pour quand même rester dans le
fond il aucun un petit peu mais un v6 et
4 qui descendent donc un petit peu
d'avancé on passe à présent à votre
dernier j'aime pas jingle donc votre
dernier j'aime pas concerne leur balle
lui handball l'équipe masculine de
versailles de notre ami alexandre
taillefer malheureusement absent
aujourd'hui bien molli bien il ne faudra
pas me contredire comme ça les a
pourtant un passage en bas c'est un
petit peu
un peu la même histoire que l'équipe de
foot du chesnay plutôt très bon en
première partie de saison les il était
en tête en tête de leur championnat à la
trêve
et puis depuis c'est un peu plus
compliqué ils ont perdu des matches
contre des concurrents directs il ya eu
il y avait eu plaisir en janvier il ya
eu le pari sport club en février
et puis le week-end dernier ce match
perdu à roissy de 2,7 buts qui
automatiquement inhibe les chances
versaillaise de remonter en n3 l'an
prochain pareil on aurait voulu avoir un
peu plus d'explications avec alexandre
sur sur les difficultés rencontrées par
son équipe
récemment puisque tout a surtout surtout
à domicile depuis depuis j'ai regardé
depuis le 17 octobre ils n'ont pas gagné
un match à domicile
j'ai un petit message perso on va on va
on va se déchaîner moi je pense que
c'est simple c'est c'est très simple il
a été trop pressant pendant les cinq
premiers mois de la saison et donc du
coup là ces joueurs sont fatigués et ils
ne peuvent plus suivre la pression qui
leur a mis depuis le début de saison
voilà je pense que c'est pour moi il
n'ya que de l'entraîneur qui viennent
restent pour saab sur 7 sur cet échec et
j'espère qu'il va comme qu'ils vont
réussir à obtenir leurs objectifs mais
voilà pour moi il pourra se défendre en
quinze jours j'ai eu alexandre taillefer
au téléphone il m'a expliqué un petit
peu la situation du club
apparemment les versailles et ont perdu
leur gardien leur gardien titulaire qui
n'est pas venu depuis deux mois à
l'entraînement
du coup il ne joue pas forcément sans
explication et par conséquent ils
encaissent beaucoup de buts
suite à son départ voilà ça c'est l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles ils sont
n'est pas la même et ouais je voudrais
dakar je voudrais juste revenir enfin
pas trop fort quand même sur yann méric
pour défendre alex quand même qu'ils
étape ça je vais faire l'avocat du
diable mais un sport collectif c'est
facile de taper sur l'entraîneur en
finale alors mais tu ne sais facile de
taper sur la teneur c'est à dire que
lorsque tout va bien c'est grâce aux
joueurs
lorsque tout va mal c'est la faute de
l'entraîneur voilà c'est ben oui mais
bon alors on connaît pas on n'a pas tous
les tenants et aboutissants tout ce
qu'on sait c'est que là les joueurs
entre le gardien qui viennent plus aux
sait plus comment on sait pas pourquoi
pardon et certains joueurs d'après ce
qu'on a d'être dû dire qu'ils viennent
plus aux étonnants c'est un petit peu
comme le football américaine la dernière
fois ci à personne c'est ça être dur de
quoi tu travailles et donc
collectivement on connaît pas on connaît
pas exactement ce qui se passe je sais
pas si alexandre leur met trop de
pression mais bon on va dire que
l'entraîneur il faut l'accepter c'est le
fusible d'un sport collectif c'est le
fusible
donc c'est plus facile de virer
l'entraîneur que le virer une équipe
guillaume l'équipe ne pourra pas monter
cette saison c'est peut-être pas là la
raison justement de cet échec sur ce
dernier match
oui c'est un peu comme ce qu'on dise ya
peut-être un manque de motivation c'est
ça c'est soit bien sûr le ch est né un
petit peu le fou du chesnay quoi c'est
que harmony si l'objectif est de monter
puis quand on voit que le tiff est pas
atteignable après la pression la
pression retombe et puis on joue le
ventre mou quoi je vous le ventre mou
sait jamais
voilà on est là bonjour ou quoi mais
rajoute pas pour un vilain petit peu la
montée ou le maintien donc c'est bien
parce qu'on s'est maintenue mais
derrière bon de l'arrivée il y avait
quelque chose après vient juste
l'appareil à la préparer l'accord
messahel peu dommage je chanterai début
de saison c'est un peu dommage de tout
cas c'est comme ça parce que justement
il faut continuer à travailler même si
le l'objectif à près de la montée n'est
puis elle n'est plus à moi mais on sait
pas a presque fait alexandre à
l'entraînement et peut-être justement il
prépare à nouveau six faillites pause
sur deux là sont d'après sur un nouveau
système de jeu je sais pas tu vois pas
celle ci via le borgne discours là parce
que je suis désolé mais quand je mets un
dossard sur le sur le maillot moi je
prends n'importe quel départ de course
j'ai toujours envie de gagner
nous quand on en 80 au départ d'une
course
il ya un vainqueur à l'arrivée tu les
deux autres à partir du 2ème on est tous
perdants bon d'accord on a bien vu ce du
cou avait moi voilà c'est donc je
comprends pas tu quand on est là sur un
sport qu on vient le dimanche on a fait
le déplacement pour venir sur un match
on a fait le débat je comprends pas
qu'on n'ait pas envie de gagner et qu'on
met pas tout en place pour les reporter
également
j'ai toujours les supporters et pour dit
pas que c'est c'est que c'est il faut
faire ça avait il dit on voit bien même
sur ton sport enfin le cyclisme sur
piste sur piste ou cheyrou la mezam la
vie s'il a fait sa petite finale il n'a
pas couru quoi donc
donc ça arrive aussi à des grands
champions de d'aller sur une compet et
se déroba je vais sur la compet soir en
préparation comme ils l'ont fait aussi
pour aller juste faire des courses
ce qu'ils appellent tournée où je publie
ce qu'ils appellent la mais voilà
déroulé comme ils appellent ça mais
voilà donc ça arrive dans tous les
sports et maintenant le en sport causse
a aussi compliqué c'est vrai que c'est
comme ils ne sont aps les ir qu'il doit
exister quand même même pour les
sportifs amateurs et encore plus précis
remettra finalement pas son plaisir et
le plaisir ceux ci la victoire réjoint
groupe conduire ensemble quoi mais bon
voilà après là je sais pas je suis pas
dans le groupe mais c'est vrai que la
motivation parfois le dessus tu es quand
tout le groupe cybit leader en tête de
jouer la montée et ses 6 ans si un mot
des alliés plus et ben tu crois que
c'est parce que je sais pertinemment que
tu t'étais or là tu es sûr de pas gagné
ben tu vas peut-être pas tout à l'heure
tu va rouler mais tu vois bien
dames et dallas où je vois la rejoint
sais que je vais rouler mais je vais
rouler en préparant pour et ben voilà
les échelons après ce départ en flammes
et ont continué cette émission par notre
rubrique le débat on passe à notre débat
du jour en football l'équipe senior de
versailles devait recevoir bobigny à
domicile à l'occasion de la 16e journée
du championnat de division honneur
le match a finalement été annulée les
joueurs de bobigny ne sont pas se sont
pas déplacés à cause d'un problème de
bus on écoute l'entraîneur de versailles
youssef chibi nous l'avions rencontrée
juste après l'annulation du match où on
veut jouer les matches vous voulez jouer
on voulait remporter sur le terrain
c'est pas notre affaire de gagner les
matchs sur dans les commissions il nous
joueurs étaient prêts pour jouer ce
match-là il rebondir suite à la défaite
de créteil
la semaine d'avant on joue dimanche pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir pratiquer pratiquer
remporté le match sur le terrain en
disputant nos chances sur le terrain et
pas avec les instances
la commission s'est finalement réuni et
a statué sur la rencontre le match
bobigny contre versailles est reporté à
une date ultérieure
le clat le club ne gagneront nous ne
gagnera donc pas le match 3 0 sur tapis
vert ce report est il un scandale
messieurs vous votez oui non si les
effets surtout sert à la remise d'accord
bien mieux fait de le séparer vie
commençait la petite idée là c'est
surtout que le bougies ils n'en sont pas
à leur premier coup
apparemment il avait des joueurs qui
étaient peut-être blessé sûr sûr sûr ce
dimanche là ou pas assez d'effectifs
pour pouvoir assurer le match et bien du
coup on dit que le bus il est en panne
ok quand on vient sur un match de foot
on vient à 15 mai 15 ça fait six
voitures et puis et puis
on est d'accord c'est que là moi je veux
bien tout attendre encore de nom mais
non mais il jouerait il jouerait il
jouait à marseille que tu dises rend la
peau pu se déplacer le problème
transports je veux bien mais là c'est
pas la faute finalement du club c'est
quand même la faute de la fédération ou
du district qui qui juge ce dossier il
ya un landau la réserve fait de rester
finalement c'est de ne pas se déplacer
et de dire ah ben on ne peut pas jouer
parce qu'on a eu un brin de mulhouse non
mais faut arrêter
ils prennent les voitures il vaut 1
bobigny versailles alors là là c'est
inadmissible les contre exemples au
rugby ou dans la stabulation rouge
entraîne ya 26 ans que les moins de 21
ans 26 des pc à anthony pour jouer au
festival n'ont pas encore joué ils sont
nés en mini vans pareil à un minivan qui
tombe en panne sur la route
donc il ya deux minutes sont arrivés à
l'heure et le troisième est arrivé en
retard le temps que la et ben ils ont
une masse perdu pas de preuves qu'ils
sont dépassés
finalement quand même mais match perdu
avec zéro point et 5 point de bonus
prend cinq points pour la victoire pour
simoneau et il n'y a pas il n'y a pas eu
de même pas que commission d'appel c'est
comme ça ce règlement basta fin veux
dire c'est scandaleux que bobigny arrive
à avoir ce match reporté sous prétexte
d'un pseudo enfin preuve de voitures ou
deux minibus l'instance du foot
ile-de-france france ile de france où en
est lyon metz le district non c'est
d'annuler les championnats de mustapha
soit pas là on aurait pu
c'est je comprends pas je vous
décidément sujet je sais pas si c'est
jack c'est déjà arrivé dans l'histoire
du sport évinois basile de voir des
choses comme ça mais moi ça arrive
fréquemment vous que des sceaux
on trouve une bonne excuse pour fermer
le stade sa pelouse
on a un effectif un peu décimés de la
richesse de la pelouse qui était pas
praticable et puis l'europe le match est
reporté ce bras ça se voit fréquemment
au niveau départemental marie faudra
soit l'amérique dans le monde où ils
évoluent même allé aux intéressés quand
même un peu plus on va dire c'est un peu
plus acceptable sur le terrain même si
c'est pareil si c'est encore comme une
esbroufe
d'accord mais c'est plus acceptable un
problème de transport bobigny versailles
c'est se moquer de la tête déjà mais
elle semble donc c'est un manque de
respect selon lui tout à fait et pareil
pour les poulets la zik de rester aussi
il faudrait changer la règle selon vos
produits mais ils ont déjà fait une fois
ça passe mais pas deux fois pas de route
et ils ont une amende parce qu'il ya un
forfait c'est une amende à un forfait
ils ont au moins deux points parce qu'en
rugby c'est moins de points aussi au
championnat et puis on en parle comme ça
ils vont pas fillon pas s'amuser à faire
faire cinquante fois c'est sûr après à
ce débat on passe au traditionnel défi
du jour
le défi concerne aujourd'hui le basket
l'équipe senior masculine du chesnay
versailles 78 s'est prêté au jeu le but
marqué entre la ligne des trois points
et le milieu de terrain il ya peut-être
des stéphane kerry wood et larry bird
dans l'équipe évinoise regarder enfin la
bat
j'ai 33 ans et je joue intérieur et mon
surnom gpat urnes j'ai suivi trente deux
ans et j'y joue les pivots ville et
alexandre 27 ans et mon poste c'est
ailier romain du boss 36 ans meneur de
jeu
à
ah ah
beaucoup d'émotion c'est le résultat
d'un mal de travail je pensais gagner
parce que je me suis beaucoup entraîné
yann une réaction par rapport à ce jeu
moi j'ai trouvé américain et donc voilà
il a avalé des grands noms mais voilà il
a le style il se prend pas au jeu et
c'est cool je pense que c'est une très
très bonne recrue pour pour versailles
le chesnay
j'espère qu'il va rester un petit moment
quand même alors y'a pas gagnée par
contre lui n'a pas gagné mais ils
s'amusent et voient ils s'amusent et
donc il apporte au groupe c'est sûr vous
êtes sûr pas que ça soit panaméricains
je sens qu'ils gagnent ce jeu mais n'ont
cédé sur ce sujet moi c'est un jeu à la
salle de la c1
voilà moi qui sais plus amusé des
difficultés supplémentaires pour ce jeu
wii wheel et d'être incompris direct
puisqu'il fallait y penser
mais que dit comment ça va bien mais
très franchement on passe à présent au
coup de gueule d'arnaud le witch vous en
avez désormais l'habitude notre
chroniqueur arnaud logo hic pouces 5
chaque émission un coup de gueule sur le
sport dans le département aujourd'hui va
le arnault va nous parler justement de
basket dans les yvelines
on vous écoute arnaud merci michael mon
coup de gueule du jour n'en est pas un
c'est plus un coup de blues un petit à
petit moment de nostalgie pour le basket
yvelinois qu'on a connu il ya quelques
années
quasiment flamboyant lectra petits
qu'ils aient des parcours jalonnée
d'exploits coupe de france qui visait la
montée en nationale une
le chesnay-versailles l'entente qui
paraît y avait des très bons résultats
et tout ça s'est un peu écroulé ces
derniers temps il reste plus qu'une
équipe évinoise en nationale 2 c'est
poissy qui a longtemps lutté cette
saison pour le maintien s'est pas
complètement terminée
le chesnay versailles est maintenant en
régionale c'est bien moins par rapport à
une certaine époque
voilà je voulais juste dire que c'est
dommage qu'on en soit arrivé là
il ya quand même un petit espoir c'est
les jeunes il ya l'élan yvelines basket
qui est une
un conglomérat devoir de maurepas de
poissy du chesnay versailles qui a été
champion de france donc on a eu 17
l'année dernière ça veut dire tiens un
vivier il ya quelque chose à construire
et voilà j'ai envie de rêver un peu de
démesure qui a encore un espoir
c'est peut-être le moment du rebond pour
le basket yvelinois vous êtes d'accord
avec arnaud c'est dramatique pour les
civils pour les yvelines d'avoir agressé
à ce point là haut niveau du basket vous
votez oui non bonsoir quasiment tous les
quinze jours
c'est les indignés d'un peuple citoyen
mais coletti dans les yvelines c'est
bien difficile quoi c'est l'image de ce
qui se dit que c'est à se demander si
c'est pas en relation avec les baisses
des subventions de l'état
je pense que les subventions d'état les
baisses sont pour tous les sports et
pour toutes les régions non 20,93
département d intensité deux clubs qui
étaient au niveau national en basket qui
sont plus importantes que dans d'autres
départements en province pato est divisé
en plusieurs parts la région de le plus
d'argent entre guillemets au bon vent au
département sensible que département 92
78 d'instaurer le vineux que ça joue si
quoi enfin y'a pas que ça mais ça joue
un petit peu quand même
on en a déjà parlé vrai qu'avec avec la
formation aussi fin aux jeunes qui
partent faire des études à droite à
gauche alors que c'est peut être pas le
cas partout
non c'est vrai qu'on est on est sur une
problématique un peu plus plusieurs
problématiques qui font que ben on a on
a cessé ses résultats qui sont en baisse
depuis depuis quelques temps du scar
jour vers le grand versailles la coupe
d'europe féminin coupe d'europe
maintenant c'est dommage comme le
soulignait arnaud c'est qu'il ya eu un
très bon projet qui a été mis en place
dans le département pour créer vraiment
une entente rassemblant les meilleurs
jeunes dans les catégories u15 u17 u18
qui rassemble donc des jeunes de quatre
clubs et les résultats sont là un
champion de france ont eu 17 parmi les
démêlés cinq six meilleures équipes en
u19 l'an dernier mais malheureusement vu
qu'il n'y a pas une équipe fanion dans
le département qui est un niveau
supérieur à la n2 dès qu'il ya des
joueurs vraiment qu'ils sortent de ce
lot sera tout de suite récupéré
parlementaire le paris levallois ou ou
d'autres clubs aux alentours il faudrait
vraiment qu'il ya un club qui puissent
voilà atteindre le niveau n 1 aux portes
du monde semi pro professionnel c'est le
lot de tous les sports co
malheureusement brian parce que le
talent le talent est là mais on peut les
accompagner jusqu'à un certain âge mais
on se salit difficile on termine cette
émission par un dernier petit débat sur
le psg virgules
le psg peut et c'est laisse éclater sa
joie les joueurs qui s'entraînent
récents germain en laye dans les
yvelines ont été sacré champion de
france dès la 30e journée un record les
parisiens se sont imposés 9 buts à 0 sur
le terrain de troyes avec un quadruplé
du suédois zlatan ibrahimovic avec 25
points d'inversion monaco le psg ne peut
plus être rattrapé et remporte donc son
sixième titre de champion son quatrième
consécutif
le recordman des victoires en
championnat reste tout de même
l'olympique de marseille avec 11 titres
remportés le psg est-il le plus beau
champion de france de l'histoire de la
ligue 1 voté oui ou non pour embêter
sermersheim situe elle entre un petit
duel entre eux bazil vous à basile et
gagnent la revanche de tout à l'heure a
dit non à les aimer aux femmes homos
c'est juste pour embêter les supporters
marseillais comme de ces jeunes sur le
plateau suisse a expliqué pourquoi je
vais juste valeur je vote contre
ok très bien mais moi j'ai même moi qui
suis supporters de marseille j'ai mis
paris vainqueur en début de saison sur
le championnat
je pense pas il fait gagner beaucoup
d'argent avec ça mais mais c'est pas
grave voilà on savait dès le début de
saison que paris serait champion est
alors en plus ça a été encore plus
facile puisque derrière ben il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas concurrence
le problème il est là c'est que le
parcours du cinquième du deuxième cette
année c'est un parcours de 5e sur une
sur un championnat classique de ligue 1
donc rolland courbis le disais quand il
est arrivé à rennes
voilà c'est juste c'est juste pitoyable
donc ça facilite sa facilité que ça
facilite la victoire de la victoire de
paris qui reste qui reste très bien
enfin voila c'est normal voilà c'est
juste logique
maintenant ce que je leur souhaite c'est
de faire un très beau parcours en ligue
des champions et au moins là ils vont
avoir
il vous montrer qu'ils ont conquise on
continue de progresser parce que ben
l'objectif c'est quand même d'aller
chercher une demi une demi là dessus
mais pour moi c'est pas le plus beau
titre de champions de france loin de là
je pense que un beau champion de france
c'est quand y'a de la confrontation et
je le dis j'ai déjà dit c'est à vaincre
sans péril on triomphe sans gloire sans
terrible non avant de créer son périple
en traîneau à ferrer avant sans caler
notait bien sûr que les lébous
championnat c'est quand à la fin ça joue
des l'argent n'est qu'il ya du suspense
que tu as maintenant faut quand même
enfin il faut les jouer ces matches là
pour les équipes qui défendent la 10
derrière il me faut marquer des buts
enfin faut fouiller les coiffes un même
site à bois vers le média qui peuvent y
avait heureusement noah s'est passée la
première ligne je suis allé voir le
match contre lorient au parc c'est un
serment ils ont ils ont joué 20 minutes
est passée la première année où il
arrive à jouer les matchs correctement
mine de rien ragued est toujours dur my
sont peut-être le bac un record de
victoires sur une saison
le bachelor corps de poing sur un
championnat enfin je veux dire c'est
quand même fait pour connaître après il
ya plus de championnat il n'y a plus de
place et comment la loi
yann de munich il ya plus de championnat
le psg comme il ya le disait tu savais
d'ores et déjà en début de saison qu'ils
allaient être champion de france
il n'y a plus aucun intérêt parce qu'il
n'ya pas de risques parce que les a
aucune il ya quand même de l'argent il
ya moins de cas de l'argent et des
messages en fait ils ont séquencé
sportive voilà sportivement ça
m'intéresse pas ça m'intéresse pas de
regarder et pendant les championnats
là ce qui m'intéresse ou de les regarder
c'est par exemple un coup d'europe
parce que là mais il se confronte à des
écuries qui sont du même niveau avec les
mains moyen et haut niveau sportif ou là
il ya une confrontation en championnat
de france
si je prends la confrontation ils
peuvent eux je viens de jouer le plus
haut point non quand on regarde et nous
qu'ils aient de match ça absolument rien
à voir avec le reste des avec lauren
vais-je même lem petit mec leur équipe b
entre guillemets fasse effet les mecs
qui perd gagne je suis désolé c'est est
ce normal et joe pavelski mais non même
l'équipe il ya des écoles pour dire que
souvenez-vous scolaire une émission sera
enregistrée on avait demandé si le pari
est d'être champion d'europe etc
moi j'avais dit qu'il serait peut-être
champion d'europe mais surtout parce que
de la tonne fera une belle saison moi
par contre je serai apte à paris qui
sont pas j'aime bien non moi j'attends
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs saison
peut-être à paris frais et se référer
pour les grands matches nuls l'approuver
pour l'instant vous pouvez en effet de
serre si ces jeunes c'est avec la baisse
de l'is celle ci est vain la hâte en
attaque on tombe sur le barça le bayern
et ça peut-être pas être la même usine l
envers en vermois mois par quoi tu prêt
à parier qu'ils seront pas champions de
noro figure pour la coupe de ressortir
les cassettes
je parie en ressentir les quatre sets
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi
à 31 mars pour un nouveau numéro de cyan
parler sport très belle soirée sûreté
les filles 78
on
oui